uh today we are going to have the third
part of the tutorial by ahmed on the
methods of static statistical physics
yeah go ahead thank you
um
so i thought i would do one more thing
about amp which is just to show you um
how can you get that iteration so
perhaps the most mysterious
term in the amp iteration was that
memory term
um i would like to show how to get that
memory term or how to derive that
iteration heuristically from just usual
message passing from a graph on a graph
and then i'll talk about the perceptron
model
and i'll use it as a very simple toy
model to make some observations about
the topics that we care about in this in
this workshop which are the
relationships between over
parameterization generalization and
efficient algorithms
so let me write down
perhaps amp again
so
this was the iteration
let me just write t here instead of l
and we had a memory term that looked
like this so which involved the
previous iteration like two steps
before
right
and dt
so okay mt
was any function that you get to pick of
this error it's you
nbt
has the following form
i t
that's it
so how do you derive something like this
if you remove this then this is just
some kind of power iteration
modulo not okay if you choose the
function f correctly then this is really
just power iteration
so how do you get something that looks
like this and i told you as well about
state evolution
let's assume the matrix is just gaussian
instead of having that spike rank one
spike i'm just going to assume that the
a i j is r
and zero one over n
so in this particular case state
evolution tells you that for any test
function see
if you look at the ul's
uts
look at the empirical distribution of
these guys
then this converges to a gaussian
so that is this is a special case of the
theorem that i showed you yesterday so i
uh the matrix a had a spike in it xx
transpose plus w w was gaussian
and furthermore i looked at test
functions that also included the spike
here x0
right in which case you get a comma here
and then another thing right
so let's just look at this special case
right
and then i'll show you perhaps uh
heuristically how this falls from from
from message passing
so what is message passing
so you're on a graph
and you're sending messages
in the following form so you're on a
vertex i
you want to send a message to versus
vertex j so this is
i this is j
you look at the neighbors of i
and you send you sum over all neighbors
of i that are not j
and put in the
matrix a
so this is k for instance
a uh
by k
the messages that k sends to i
so this is the iteration
so if you want to send a message here
you just look at all the messages that
come from the neighbors of i that are
not j then you do something with them
and then you send the message right in
particular i applied a function ft to
each one of them i could get to choose
it however i want
and i just sum over the weights
so the edges
here are associated to the weight so the
weights are associated to the to the
edges of this graph the weights being
the aijs right
and you get to
initialize however you'd like so for
instance i'll initialize
at time 0
by a ui that doesn't depend on j and
let's say it's gaussian whatever
okay we can start with the calcium
so what does
ui towards j1 so at step one what does
it look like
so this is a i
k ft
fuk zero
right this is a gaussian
but
more importantly this is independent of
this
right
so if you condition on these guys
then this is just just a sum of
gaussians which means that this is also
a gaussian
the variance being the second moment of
this guy
okay condition along these right
so now let's move on to step two
so i'll write this again
one
all right now you have to
pay a little bit more attention
so you're looking at the messages so you
so the main thing you're going to try to
do is to understand the dependence
between this randomness and this
randomness right in order to make a
claim about what the distribution of the
iterators is right
and then you can see that these two are
independent because
u sub k to i when k sends some message
to i it sums over all the neighbors of i
that are not j right
and those weights
are independent of this so if you look
at
since let me see perhaps i should write
exactly what
this message is right
l
minus
right
okay
so since l so we'll compare these two
right since l is different from i
these two are independent these two are
not the same right
so if you condition on this this is
still a gaussian
right and you keep you can keep playing
this game as long as the graph has a
large girth you can keep playing this
game and you can still making the same
claims right
zero
okay
so you get the idea why the error should
be gaussian right so this is yes
no so there's no central limit theorem
you could do the central limit theorem
if you initialize in a different way but
here these are really just like proper
gaussians
right and my matrix is gaussians it's
just a linear combination of those since
it's still gaussian yes perhaps
but this is not going to work i mean it
worked the first disc but it's not going
to work in the next step because now you
have the tendencies so if the graph is
a tree okay
your phone right so if the graph has a
larger girth
then you're fine right
up to the current up to the okay up to
the guard that's fine right but then
you're going to have to start tracking
the the the dependencies right but here
i'm looking at the opposite of that
situation for amp the graph is the
complete graph so this argument fails at
step three exactly right so i'll show
you now what happens
okay good question
let me tell you now how to get amp from
vp
right so if the graph is the complete
graph
then you can look at one iterates so at
any point in time
okay
and that's the sum over the neighbors i
minus j
so you're in the complete graph so this
is just the sum over all k's that are
not i
is this correct yes
right
so i can so i have only one term that is
that is excluded here i can try to
include it
and then subtracts it back
minus and i'll subtract the term that
corresponds to j
c
j towards i t right
so you can see that this term doesn't
depend on j right it's just a sum that
only depends on i
and the only contribution of j is this
term
but this term is small right this term
because a i j is
a galaxy with this much variance this
term is of order whenever square root n
right
so we can hope since the graph is
complete it's a complete graph you can
perhaps
try to simplify this iteration instead
of saying that
i will send an individualized message to
every one of its neighbors you can just
try to set a bulk message to everybody
right so the messages that you can try
to hope to send
rds which i'm gonna call
just u i t plus one but let me write it
more explicitly it's really just this
okay towards i
right
so i removed the dependency on j but now
i have to see how this thing evolves
when you do an iteration of vp
right so
i write it
sorry
so let me write k towards i this message
in full
so k towards i
is the sum over i always
so this is j this is i this is k and i
have to sum over the neighbors
of k i'm going to call them l
so l
there are the neighbors of k that are
not i right
and since you're in the complete graph
this is just what it is
a okay
c minus 1
u l 2k
correct
this is what it is
now i can play the same game here so
i can add and subtract the terms that
corresponds to i
but then you're going to have to be
careful
okay from 1 to n
a ift
sum over all l from 1 to n of this 10
right but that's what
that's u
c
minus the term that corresponds to i
here
so
ik
minus
y2k
okay
so this term is of order 1 over square
root n
so i isolated uc i added a term i added
the term and subtracted that same term
and that term
exactly corresponds to the ik
so whatever you're multiplying by here
it shows up also here
so basically what happens here is that
you're
when you're doing message fasten you're
not you're you're
you're doing a an iteration that sums
over non-backtracking parts you don't
want to backtrack back to where you were
so the only dependency
in this term
between these two
is through
exactly that same
weight which is
ki right
now i can just do a first order taylor
expansion of f around this so this is
small this is of order one presumably
ftf uk t
and then i have minus
sum over k
from 1 to n
then i have a k i a i k which is the
same so
this guy gets squared
i have
f t minus 1 of u i to k this term
and then i multiply by ft of this f
prime excuse me
f prime c
[Music]
now i have a dependence on k here i
would like to get rid of it
right
then i can try to play the same game
again just add and subtract the term
that makes this uh k go away right but
then i have an error of one over square
root n here
okay
now the claim is that this doesn't
matter
you can try to do it and you'll see if
you do it the term that's going to
multiply these k i's are is are going to
be independent so this 10 is going to be
independent of this therefore it's going
to go away
because it has expectation zero it has
variance one over n to the power three
halves
this is square and this is one over
square root of n it's going to be n to
the power three halves right
so that doesn't matter so i get i get to
stop at this at this stage so here i'm
allowed to remove the k from here
and add
1 over square root of that
okay
so if i do that then this doesn't depend
on k anymore
the only sum the only thing that k hits
or this sum hits is this pin and this
thing
right and this come out comes out but
this is exactly bt
right that term that appears in message
passing right
this is
yeah if t has to be regular if it's ft
is not regular we would have to regular
regularize it yeah yeah it has to be
lifted so
right so at the end so what do i get as
an iteration i get u i
t plus 1
equals
okay
ft
hey
minus
a
k squared
prime
ft minus 1 of ut minus 1k
right so this is not exactly
bt
but this thin concentrates around 1 over
n
because it has variance one over and
this sum will concentrate around one
over n
this thing will concentrate
around the expectation
of distance so i can just replace this
and here there is a one over n here
because it comes from this one
all right so this is bt
and then you have ft minus one if you k
t minus one
right so this is exactly the amp
iteration so if you call these guys mt
so and this is mg minus one
then
you get u t plus one so in vector form
so this is just for every coordinates on
its own in vector form this is what it
is
so that's how you get amp
so amp comes just by tracking the
dependence between
when you write down the message passing
iteration just track
what's going to have an effect and
what's not going to have an effect and
it turns out that the only thing that
has an effects are backtracking loops if
you have
so
you're sending a message from let's say
a i to j and you're not allowed to
backtrack in message passing but then if
you try to allow yourself to backtrack
you're going to have to track the
dependence what what kind of error does
this backtrack can introduce to your
algorithm
and it turns out that the only effects
of this is to introduce this memory term
right so graphically you can see it like
this you're not allowed to backtrack and
message pass in but if i want to
backtrack in the complete graph then the
only effect of that backtracking is to
introduce this memory term
right that's it so perhaps not in your
question about that the argument doesn't
extend
it works up to
distance two
right
but then the claim is that in a dense
graph distance three and above is
subdominant it goes away
because of this thing that i said here
is that so here i had a k
but then if i try to remove this k and
add a one over square root n here
then this one over square root n hits a
one over n it gets me n to the one to
the power three halves which is
subdominant compared to the main
quantities here
so for uh for a for a complete graph the
only thing that matters is just a
two-step thing so just backtracking like
this
okay so
we're very surprised we're fine because
there are no uh short cycles correct
for a dense graph we're fine because
the the local stuff just gets washed
away by the yeah correct so what's the
best situation
so the back situation would be a
complete graph where the weights are not
small
so here my weights are mean zero
variance one over n
so if you have a complete graph but the
weights are not small if the weights
were one
then this doesn't doesn't work right so
really what makes it work is that so
you're you're making the graph denser
suppose you have a sparse graph now try
to make it denser but then you're
lowering the weights of every edge so
that you're still in the same regime
more or less right
so you're going to have to have weights
that are small if you have the
dense graph so that you can wash away
the long-range dependencies
yeah that's a good question
so this is how you get the algorithm and
you see okay so this is an exercise it's
nice and okay
i think there is a proof of this you
know a rigorous version of this by leia
and uh and uh javon mars
of landmark
but um
perhaps one thing to take away from this
is that algorithmically if you're
interested in the algorithm here you
have to track n squared messages right i
change j
and your simplify needs to track only n
messages so you're reducing the
complexity of your algorithm by a
quadratic factor right n squared versus
n and you're still having the same
behavior
so state evolution you can see state
evolution as a
reminiscent fact from
the message fascinating iteration that
it's always gaussian because you're not
allowed to backtrack it's always
gaussian but this preserves that
structure as long as you're adding this
memory term okay so that perhaps that's
all i have to say about this
so if you look at the physics papers or
the physics papers that start to study
machine learning problems they do a lot
of this distance so i wanted to show you
this because this is what happens in a
lot of those arguments
okay good
so now let me switch gears i want to
talk about the perceptron problem
so perhaps i'll present the perceptron
problem in a way that is
slightly unfamiliar but this is the
version that the probabilists like
so i have a bunch of gaussian vectors
in n dimension
and i have m of them
it's their id
and i'm trying to look
search for a vector okay i have another
parameter kappa
and i'm trying to search for
find
right
theta
that is either in plus minus one you can
choose it to be either binary or
on the sphere if you'd like
of the same radius
such that
all of these linear inequalities are
satisfied
okay
so you have a bunch of data points and
you're trying to look for a hyperplane
that has a margin at least kappa when
multiplied when you test all of those
points against that linear function
right
and this is perhaps related to the
maybe you can see it as a separator okay
linear separator
and if you care about learning this is a
very simplistic model so you have data
and you're looking for a function f
which is
perhaps just a sine
x minus kappa
and you would like to find so this is
related it's not exactly the same thing
but it's related so
find
data such that
equals y i for all i right
so similar problem
turns out that this problem okay so the
questions that you could ask when you
have such a problem depending on whether
okay so either i fixed binary or sphere
i can ask
for fixed m and n so m is the number of
constraints n is the dimension
does this problem have a solution or not
so for what values for what comparative
values of m and n does this problem has
a solution as a function of kappa
then when there exists solutions can i
find them efficiently
and
now when they exist solutions what do
they look like what does the space of
solutions look like so these are the
kind of questions that we
ask right turns out okay so there is a
long history of this in stat phys the
there's a conjecture about what is the
satisfiability threshold of this there
is a bound that was derived by
sun and ding
but it's still an open problem to derive
the other bounds um
but a much easier problem to study
so remark that i can
make the inequalities go the other way
without without loss of generality
because this is a gaussian right
symmetric
now the problem that is a lot easier to
study is if i put absolute values here
so this is called the symmetric
perceptron
and i'm just going to let me just focus
on the binary case
so the
symmetric binary perceptron
is that so
data
binary
such that for all
i
kappa square root n
so i'm putting a square root n here
because this is a vector of size square
root n if i divide it this is just a
univariate gaussian right
so
okay this whole thing is universal
gaussian of means zero variance one
so you can ask questions about when is
this satisfiable when can you find the
solutions of this form
so if i ask you that you can try to find
one and
find the sufficient condition for an
algorithm to work but let's not do that
yet because that's a hard question an
easier thing is to just count the number
of solutions right
in expectation
and if that's expectation is negative
that means are not negative if it goes
to zero that means that there are no
solutions
and this is called the moment method so
let me introduce the moment method
this is a combinatorial argument so this
is acting to the probabilistic technique
yeah
why do you want to study this problem
there are many reasons so people studied
this because of neural nets really how
is this related to your lips why you can
just look at it as a linear customer
well
the absolute value this is format this
is because i'm a mathematician this is
just really purely because of math
because we can prove things in this
setting and we cannot prove the things
when there is no when there's no
absolute buttons the conjecture the
physicists believe is that the landscape
doesn't change it's the same properties
the problem is easier mathematically
but the phenomenology is still the same
and i'll show you what happens
completely different problem right i
mean because
when you did that
we're generally interested okay so this
is right
yes the problems with negative very
generally interested with tip x i being
uh
positive
and this really only makes when you when
you do the sign change you really are
now looking at kind of a negative
perception you're looking at a negative
margin right there's no longer i think
we're really interested in separability
yeah and in order for this to make sense
before you've flipped you have to talk
about non-separability yeah and then so
why would we think that it has anything
to do with the no it doesn't that's
that's the motivation that's like the
the your motivation is to study problems
where there is no absolute value and i'm
saying that if i change the problem like
this then i can prove things about it
and i believe that's the same same thing
was still true okay so that last
statement is there any reason to think
that oh yeah yeah yeah so this is
because of the if you try to do the
cavity method and those things then they
they get the qualitatively the same with
the same results so the math is much
harder
but the phenomenology and this is like
this is what probably theory is about
it's like you look for simple models
that preserve the same structure and
there's universality like
why would this problem be much much
different than the one where there is no
absolute value right
like the same thing happens like
but this is like perhaps a different
approach than what it's typically taken
in other fields but yeah you try to
develop methods to study these things
and then you start with the easiest case
and i think the best is
why can't they change to nicely
succeeded again
uh why the inequality can be changed to
less than oh if i don't if i remove the
absolute values then i can change the
sign i mean module changing capital by
minus kappa but x is symmetric right x
and minus x have the same distribution
so i think that maybe because i know it
confused me for a long time because if
you can change it but then you have to
be fine with having a negative margin
like if you don't think there's a
difference in having a and actually
having a margin
and having a negative margin which means
things are not actually separable
i mean that's because that that k
it's actually is the negative
so right so let's do this again so i
started like this
right
now if you put minus signs then you do
this right but then the minus signs goes
here and this is also an x prime i which
has the same distribution right but then
you change the margin as much he says
from positive to negative negative to
positive
make sense
right this is really
so now the kappa is negative right yeah
i mean i didn't tell you that couple is
positive to begin with
[Laughter]
is the problem without the absolute
value is also like is a solution
or
solution with the solution in the sense
the things that you're going to show us
can you also do it without the absolute
value but it's harder or is it not yeah
well you can try to do certain thing
limited things
let me let me just get you i'll talk
about the parallels i'll talk about
parallels
so you can ask what is the when are
there solutions to this problem okay so
the first thing you can try to do is
just count the number of solutions
right
so that's
this thing happens
now if i take the expectation of this
this is an easy problem
the sum of theta is expectation if this
is just the probability of this then
these are independents constraints okay
the xi's are independent so you get the
probability
that theta x i is smaller than kappa
squared
to the power of m
just x1 right
because these are independent
strengths are independent
but what is this this is a universal
calcium multiplied by when you divide by
square root this is an invariant calcium
right this is just a universe notes
so let me take kappa
p of kappa to be that probability that
the univariate gaussian is smaller than
kappa this is just a number
so this is 2 to the power n this thing
doesn't depend on theta
it's times p
to the power of n
it's a really simple computation
so if the expectation goes to zero that
means that there are no solutions in our
probability one visit the expectation go
to zero
so this will go to zero if
this is this is larger than one this is
two this is smaller than one so it's a
competition competition between these
two terms
and this will go to zero as m
is larger than minus log two
for log p of comma
so this is the first moment
right
so no solutions with higher probability
if this is true
[Music]
right so i'm going to call this number
of kappa
so no solutions
with high probability of
alpha let me call alpha the ratio
between m and n
and alpha is uh
larger
than offset
there are too many constraints to
satisfy all of them right
it turns out so one reason you put the
absolute value is that it turns out that
this very simple bound is checked
right it is right
if i didn't put the absolute values then
this value would be wrong
okay so this is one reason
it's a lot easier to study the symmetric
problem than to study the non-symmetric
problem
so how do you prove that this is the
right bounds um this is
you have to do the second moment so for
instance if i want to prove that z
is positive
greater than one this is an integer so i
want to prove that this thing
goes to one for instance
then i can use what's called the pity
segment inequality
it turns out that this is larger than
the ratio
second moment the first moment squared
over the second moment
this is just by pushy schwartz this is
called the phase signal
right
so therefore if
second moment
is bounded by a constant times the first
moment squared
if i can prove something like this
then the probability that z is positive
is greater than one over c
which is positive
so i can prove i can't prove it without
probably beliefs using this method i can
prove it with positive probability
right
so the only thing that remains to show
is that the second moment is bounded by
a constant times the first moment
squared
right then you can ask about the
question now can i boost this to high
probability statements right instead of
having positive product belief solution
existing solutions existing
can i boost that to a statement about
high probability this method will not
give you that you're going to have to
work a lot harder
but this is uh this is so this is uh
maybe just 101 constraint satisfaction
problems right this is this is what the
perhaps the first class on constraint
satisfaction will teach random concerns
so we try to compute the second moment
what time it is
okay let me not do the second
moment but it's a computation that is
very nice
and you can do it really it's not hard
and basically what you've got is that
the second moment is n
if you do the laplace method you get
that this is n times the maximum of a
certain function
of the parameter q
and the parameter q i keep writing the
same q a here and this is the same queue
that appeared in the replica symmetric
formula this is the same two that
appeared in emp instead of
is just the overlap between two replicas
when you take two independent copies
from the solution space look at their
overlap what is the most likely overlap
right
and this function will look like this
so this is zero minus one
one
it's symmetric
okay i'm not gonna be able to draw a
symmetric function but bear with me
like this
so you're understanding you're trying to
understand the maximum the maximum is
either here or
plus or close to plus or minus one turns
out that by the magic of the absolute
value again
if alpha
is smaller than alpha such
if alpha is smaller than alpha sat
and this is not hard to prove again
then the maximum of that function
maximum
is achieved at zero
minus 1 1
is achieved at 0
which means that
most likely if you take two solutions at
random when you take their overlap take
their inner product the inner product is
zero so most solutions are orthogonal to
each other
right
so the maximum is here so this is this
value is lower this value is lower
and it turns out when you compute
p of zero
and therefore
the second moment is exponential n times
v is zero it turns out that this is
exactly the expectation of
z squared it's just this thing squared
four to the power n
p of kappa to the power two m
okay
so this is one thing that the second
moment tells you
okay so
therefore solutions exist
if
alpha smaller than alpha set with
positive probability
if alpha is smaller than alpha
okay so we identified the satisfiability
threshold
which is this
so now take alpha smaller than that
and then ask whether you can find
solutions or not
an earlier question that i can ask is
what does the space of solutions look
like right
it turns out that all solutions are
isolated most solutions are isolated
and that comes perhaps
heuristically from this picture if you
take two
copies at random
solutions that random independently you
look at their overlap the statement that
the maximum is achieved at zero tells
you that the overlap between two
solutions is going to be
zero right they're going to be
orthogonal
and then you can extrapolate that to say
perhaps yeah one of you
uh
alpha greater than alpha means there are
more constraints
there cannot exist more solutions in
best situations alpha smaller than alpha
such
so no solutions if alpha is greater than
alpha
solution is in the opposite direction
uh given that this second movement is
exactly the first square constant is a
constant
no otherwise you have the exact
concentration yeah yeah
sure
yeah i'm a little kind of confused like
why would the
why would the
um like expected overlap of any two
solutions have anything to do with the
solutions existing in the first place
like to me that describes what you're
talking about now which is like how is
the solution
yeah but
like aren't we assuming that solutions
exist
no yeah no no so here this is just uh
maybe just the way i understand it so
it's just a heuristic thing to say so
you're looking you're
suppose you're below satisfiability so
you have solutions and then you take two
of them you look at their overlap and
look at what is the most likely value
for that inner products
right i claim that that's given by
the maximum of this function
i did not prove that but that's what i
think
but the thing that is related to proving
whether there is solutions or not is
computing the actual second moment
that's that's a fine denture rule right
so now it turns out that the space of
solutions really is
a bunch of singletons
theorem is
for all alpha smaller than alpha sat
so this is by ave
and sly
and also
perkins
and sue
2021 i think
so this was conjectured in physics this
has been known conjecturally for a while
but then the proof came a bit later for
all alpha for all densities whenever the
problem
is satisfiable whenever there are
solutions most solutions so a solution
perhaps a more rigorous way to say the
solution picked uniformly at random
at random
is isolated
with high probability
isolated and isolated really means that
there there's a linear hamming distance
between solutions
the closest solution to this one is a
linear distance linear n
away from it
okay so if most solutions are like this
how can you possibly find a solution it
seems like an impossible task this is a
problem that is you have extreme
clustering right
now if you think of an algorithm that
just does
you know local moves then there is no
way you can jump from one to another so
how can you find solutions at all right
so this is a puzzle maintained
yet there are algorithms that find
solutions
so it's been known that certain
heuristics work
and you can look at this problem from
the point of view of discrepancy theory
and there are many many algorithms from
discrepancy that will solve this problem
for you you're going to have to work
hard to prove that they work but they
work
so
yet
algorithms exist
but they exist at very small alpha
exist
that's small
alpha
[Music]
turns out that they cannot exist in
large alpha it is it's a proof
they cannot exist in blockchain
right
so the solution space is completely
clustered and then yet solutions exist
so here's a so this is a conundrum why
is that the case turns out that
this is an empirical observation
also algorithms that work the heuristic
that works
will find solutions that are connected
to many other solutions
so whenever a heuristic succeeds
empirically
it turns out that it finds a solution
that is connected to many other
solutions
but i just told you that most solutions
are isolated
so efficient algorithm must go into an
exponentially error region in the
solution space that find solutions that
are connected to each other
right how does how does that happen why
is that the case right so this is a
problem that we don't know how to under
we don't understand yet
and you can show that certain you you
can show that such structures actually
exist not just heuristically not just
because of empirical observations
there's a theorem by the same people
that shows that there exists this thing
that is called the wide web so
another theorem is
there exists
exit components
connected components
of
maximal diameter of okay diameter to n
with high probability
when
alpha is small enough
so if you pick a solution at random
you'll never find it here if you just
pick a solution at random from the
entire space they're not going to land
interconnected components but they exist
right
but the crazy thing is that efficient
algorithms will land you there
right so efficient algorithms do not
sample uniformly they will get you there
so this is yeah this is this is uh
something that we don't understand
can you see what basically
isolated if you pick a solution at
random
what is then then start growing a radius
and then stop when you find another
solution in that radius right
and that radius that you have to go with
is linear in
timing distance yeah just flipping
coordinates right
so this is something that is that is
very similar to generalization to the
the question of over parameterization
and uh the efficient algorithms that
work under over parameterization so over
parameterization here means that the
number of constraints is much smaller
number of data points that you get the
xi's is much smaller than the dimension
which means that alpha is small right
so how algorithms exist and we don't
understand why
so the question here perhaps from the
point of view of this theory is what is
the structural property of distribution
space that makes this thing happen
so
what's property
is responsible
for this behavior
yeah
but why do we care about finding the
concept
you don't care about that that's what
you get
you don't care about that you just want
to find a solution
but then when you do your algorithm if
it works it'll get you a cluster
so perhaps another claim is that so this
is not proven but it's believed that you
cannot find these solutions if they're
isolated you cannot find them
the only solutions you can find are the
good ones which are in a dense
have you cluster what the algorithms
that find these solutions i did not um
there are a few um
there is one for instance by kim and
roche which does this majority
multi-scale majority algorithm so this
is your matrix of the data so the x's
are like this
and the theta is here and you want this
to be let's say smaller than kappa right
what you do is you partition
your matrix into blocks
the first one you just initialize
however you'd like
then you choose these guys in a way that
will
push you below
and also that doesn't change too much
that only adds noise to the rest of the
coordinates basically so you want to
this is a you have inequalities here you
have one two three up to m inequalities
right you choose one
you try to push this one below kappa
but then you don't want to hurt yourself
in the other ones
right and there is a way to do this
there is it's called multi-scale
majority it's a very nice algorithm it
works yeah
so there's an algorithm that looks like
this there's another algorithm from
discrepancy theory that is based on
i don't really remember
what is it based on some kind of
potential you try to minimize some kind
of potential when you try to
move inside the cube
and then you would like to get to the
corners of the cube so that you have to
round at some point to get to the
corners of the cube there's something
like this i don't remember exactly
so
the physicists tried to look at this
following
construction so they say what they say
is
here's a proposal you can look at the
what's called the local entropy what
time is it
when am i done
yes
local entropy
so the local entropy what is that so you
look at a reference solution
and then you look at solutions that are
around it
a distance r or n times r
and count them you count them
and then you plot that function
so one particular wave so how do you
choose this particular reference
solution so that's another thing so
here's one proposal that you can
mathematically make sense
so i'm going to let's so let the space
of solutions be
sx this is the the data and then kappa
is the margin
i'm going to let a solution theta 0
be in here
kappa prime prime and i'm going to let
kappa prime be a slightly smaller margin
than kappa
so this solution so pick a uniformly at
random then you're going to land
somewhere that is isolated so the
solution will be isolated
but then the point is here so the
observation is that as you start
increasing
kappa
more solutions will show up around it
so what you have is
zero
x i
smaller than kappa square root n
kappa prime square root n
when you start increasing kappa prime
then this is still a solution right it's
not a problem but the point is more
solutions are going to start showing up
when you increase data there weren't
solutions before
and one claim is that smart solutions
are going to start to show up around
this one
so this one becomes no longer isolated
right it's no longer isolated but that's
fine because it's not typical anymore
in this new ensemble when you increase
kappa that solution is not typical
anymore it's not drawn from the uniform
measure of the new solution such right
so this is the claim and now you can
count how many of these are
right so my function
r will be
just count
the number of y's
that are in the solution set for kappa
larger than kappa prime
and such that
they have a distance hamming distance
from the original
solution that is n times r
okay i'm going to take the logarithm of
this
that gives me an entropy
and then i'm going to average over theta
zero
a prime
average over the size of s
right
and take an expectation over x
right so this is a deterministic
function
so this is what the local entropy looks
like this is one possible definition of
the local entropy
so the crazy thing that
is conjectured is the following so this
is there are no theorems here this is
really like this is just speculations
so if you draw this function as a
function of
r and then either it looks like this
it looks like this
this is picture by the way i need to
credit this to buzz
many co-authors akina
and others i don't like i can't remember
all of them but this is perhaps from
2020.
so what they say is if the function
looks like this so of course that so the
the this function depends on kappa kappa
prime and alpha
now fix
kappa prime and alpha and k prime and
kappa and change alpha turns out that's
the behavior is that when you increase
alpha
this is what happens so for alpha very
very small the function is strictly
increasing
if you keep increasing alpha at some
point it's going to gain a local maximum
if you keep increasing alpha is going to
be negative
and the the what they say is that this
is the algorithmically easier gene
this is hard
and if it's negative there's no
solutions
but okay both of these are hard let's
see there are solutions but not close to
close to the the reference solution
this is hard this is hard let's say
so this is a property whatever this
property is okay so they give a
particular property of the solution
space but this is independent of
algorithms
right
that doesn't have to do anything with
the algorithms it's just a property of
the space that tells you whether the
problem is easy or hard
this is perhaps in contrast to what nadi
said in in his talk that
that it depends on the algorithm that
not just the generalization but the
faculty of finding a solution will
depend on the other things
algorithm-specific and if you change the
algorithm you get a new effective
regularization here i'm looking at
interpolator so everything gets to
minimum zero error so here i'm in the
satisfiable regime right and this is a
property that does not depend on the
algorithm
so if this happens then the problem will
be easy if this doesn't happen the
problem will be hard this is all
conjectural of course we don't know how
to prove these things yet
okay
so perhaps let me now
try to generalize this picture
and just ask questions i have nothing to
prove but i'm not
i don't have any new results to prove
here but perhaps the questions are the
most interesting
so now if you look at
erm yeah
so even if it has a maximum
why is that
right so
the way to think about there are a few
ways to think about it one way to think
about it is that an algorithm somehow
will start here and i'm just going to
try to increase to maximize this go
along the steepest slope of this entropy
function it's like when you look at the
rs formula
then a and p will try to get to the
nearest global maxima from whatever
you're starting
turns out if you escape that means that
the problem is easy i don't know okay so
if you want to if you want a more
convincing heuristic i need to tell you
about full rsp and i don't want to talk
about foreign
but um this is the picture that they
this is empirical this is really just
incurred
social you look at erm
so you have data
some distribution and you would like to
minimize
this
over data
so you have a function class that is
parametrized by theta you would like to
minimize this
and if the function class is large
enough then you have interpolators you
can get to zero error so suppose that
the function the loss function
this is positive but then
when you take for any y and you take the
minimum over x this is zero so you can
drive this to zero for all y
for y and plus minus one
right so
then
if the function class is large enough
you can get interpolators
which is the sets i'm going to call it s
of all the thetas such that
l of f data x i
y i
is zero
right
and
[Music]
one specific example of this is this
story that i told you if you pick
f the function class and the loss
function adequately you get really the
perceptron right so
for instance
if l
f x y
it's this function
and f theta of x
is just data
uh sine perhaps sine
cosine
that's it
right so
in which case
in which case you get that this set s
is
a set of data such that you want to
drive this to zero so the inequality
will flip when this is zero
y i
smaller than
square root now
for all i
okay so now you can recall you can call
x i y i another x i nice and that gives
you the perceptron problem
right so this is a special case of the
erm framework if you care about
interpolation
so what is over parameterization here
means so m is the number of samples that
you get the number of the size of the
data set
and n i didn't say n okay n is the
dimension of the data
right
so n has to be much larger than m that's
the over parameterized regime
right
um
in that case
you land in the same regime that we were
looking at so m
was larger than n
i'm much smaller than n so that means
that alpha
is small
right
so alpha is m over n
right so the over parameterization just
means that the number of constraints is
mu smaller than number that the
dimension
and that's the behavior that i showed
you what happens for the perceptron when
you're in this overparameterized regime
most solutions are bad the ones that you
find efficiently are somewhat good like
they're connected to other solutions so
how does that happen right so that's one
question now you can generalize this now
if you once you understand this
connection you can try to generalize
this so perhaps i'll just end with a few
questions that i
am interested in
so
the first one is can you find a model of
neural networks
and we find
a model
neural networks perhaps let's just say
maybe just two linear to two layer
such that
if we pick
a parameter theta at
random from the set of interpolators
right so this is these are the weights
of your neural net data is the weights
of your neural nets then
the generalization error
is maximal
whatever maximal means
right so rf data
is a generalization error
can you do this okay is this is this is
this true
if you pick it uniformly at random
then the generalization error is maximal
and the analogy is that when you pick
uniformly at random points from the
perceptron problem and you get an
isolated solution okay isolated doesn't
mean generalization is bad i don't know
what that means but
okay so perhaps this is something that
we can think about right
so the second question is
about the exceptional set
okay bad here maximal with high
probability
yeah
yeah
[Music]
yeah so you're gonna have to define what
generalization error mean in the case of
the perceptron
and i'm considering the data that is
independent of the y so it's really so x
and y so this is random noise the the
labels are just random they're not
related to the x's in which case the
generalization area is always going to
be maximal because there is no
correlation between x and y
right and that's just a one-line proof
there's no so
this question is trivial in this case so
if you want to ask this question in a
more meaningful way you're going to have
to assume a generic model that ties x
and y for instance by logistic
regression
is the answer known if you assume this
kind of generated
not to this degree of granularity so i
think there is a picture about andrea
and i think one of his postdocs that
studies the perceptron problem on the
sphere that's when data is generated
from an actual like legit model
they prove certain things about
algorithms when can you find the
solution and is it correlated to the
planetary
and but this question is fine growing
questions about isolation
that's not studied
the second question is about the
exceptional set is does there exist
a substance
inside the set of interpolators i'm
going to call a that has very small
volume
the volume is much smaller comparatively
to s
such that
the generalization error of theta
is very small
for all
data in a
right so there's an exceptional set that
generalizes exceptionally good
so you can think about this set as those
dense clusters that show up in the
perceptron problem
the third question
does gradient descend land in a
so in which case this is a property of
the problem this is not a property of
the algorithm right the existence of
this set a is the property of the
problem
right
now you would assume perhaps like for
the perceptron problem that as you
increase so here we're in the over
parametrized regime we're in the the
regime where where alpha is very small
but you would expect that as you
increase alpha then this set will no
longer exist right
so okay does there exist this set
when does it exist when does it exist
doesn't it not exist as a function of
alpha and can you determine that
right and the fact whether the set
exists or not is that due to a property
another more deeper proper property of
the problem
they can try to study
so okay so this is uh these are a few
questions that you can ask about about
such problems and they're somewhat they
seem a lot more i mean they're very hard
i think
but
the draw or maybe their appeal is that
they don't involve studying the problem
on an algorithmic specific basis like
don't you have you don't have to pick an
algorithm and then study the problem as
a function of that algorithm right it
separates study in the problem versus
the algorithm which is what we're used
to do in classical statistical theory
all right okay perhaps i'll stop here i
don't have anything more to say thank
you
but let's thanks
you